yeah I think that the biggest
misconceptions and I think those what
rondo saying is absolutely true that as
idea patients which I was never really a
patient person I've had to learn
patience the idea that it's just going
to happen sooner rather than later zyzz
usually is not dizzy more often not to
get this is going to take a while so you
do have to settle in for the long a long
journey most of us do and logic is the
other thing like that there's a lot
there is no logic to have this business
operates I was always of the feeling and
you mentioned this that like talent
without like somehow if the better
filmmaker wins is what I thought in
other words part of a partly when I was
in film school trying to become the best
filmmaker was that I felt like my
competition wouldn't be competition
would go a little easier if I was a
better filmmaker it just makes sense the
better man wins it's sort of like you
know not just in film but they didn't
all business they kind of teach you that
if you work harder if you're better at
the job d you will rise I want you to do
is look around at the kind of I don't
say I'm the best filmmaker but all you
do is look around the slew of hacks
working our movies that have almost no
business a lot of them have no business
making movies making a ton of money and
making movie after movie or like we'll
wait a minute there's no really there's
forget justice there's no justice anyway
and then in the world at all it's no
logic you know so as the years go by I
sort of like in this town to Las Vegas
it is closer to Las Vegas than it is to
you know Broadway or thiet la is like
Las Vegas it's a gambler's town
everybody who's here trying to be in
show this is a gambler you have to have
that that has to be part of your
personality anyway otherwise you
wouldn't just come to California and not
do a nine-to-five job and some students
said to me the other day like well what
about your retirement plan and I was
like what why like I don't know what I
don't why don't overtalk like
you have to be willing to gamble and I
you know I don't gamble like I don't
play I don't gamble anyway all I ever
did was play slots but here's the here's
the kind of correlation if you stay at
the machine that that's it of one
machine and you keep pulling eventually
it will hit and so that's sort of the
symbol or image i have about sticking
you just stay at the frickin machine and
you keep pulling and the longer you stay
at that thing while you're willing to
hang on despite the fact that there are
no there's no logic to when it's going
to happen or why the longer you stay
there sooner or later it will hit and
then talent will serve you if you
haven't be talented on top of that then
chances are you won't [ __ ] up that
opportunity you've been given and
someone will go okay well he's got that
going for him I knowing one [ __ ] it up
so maybe that puts you slightly more
ahead of the unknown guy but yeah those
are hard lessons to learn because when
you take that out of the equation and
all directors are control freaks
otherwise it wouldn't be director to try
to control and make this thing you
realize that the business you're working
in doesn't follow any rules it's it's a
hard it's a hard pill to swallow for
somebody who's trying to where you're
trying to govern your life John Gorman
said recently john boarman excalibur
deliverance and helping Lori a ton of
Point Blank ton of movies said this
business is about all moves you didn't
get to make and I was like jeez is
correct that is a dark comment but it
shows you that you know even for a
successful filmmaker there's a lot of
things that you don't get to do so you
have to be willing to hang on for that
may be the few times that you are going
to get to make a movie you gotta say
that's worth it to me or don't do it
live another life and be happy if you
mehak obviously you can be happier than
anything else do it don't don't you know
you suffer that much less yeah anytime
anyone ever asks me what plan B is I
just throw my arms I go on
I really really wish I had a plan B I
really wish there was something else
that I would could do really so
passionate about doing and there's not
so I'm stuck right what I'm wondering
too though is I know someone told me
this quote one time they said that
usually people that care the least
usually end up getting certain things
I'm have nothing been too hungry and I
have to look at this for myself as well
being too hungry hurts people sometimes
because it seems like sometimes people
that can rest on their laurels a little
bit and have more of a discretion no I
don't want this it's almost like this
thing what I'll see more valuable than
they really are yeah well I mean I do
think that the tents tension and like
you know a real sort of like I gotta get
this I got him to make a mood you know
if you if you let that part of your of
your personality become the dominant
force you can appear the crazy you can
appear desperate you can you can maybe
that will work against you but also I
think a creative process doesn't it
doesn't serve the creative process I
mean to be creative in anything to be
good in anything it's whether it's arts
or sports you have to like relax at the
moment of creativity at the moment of
doing you think about it too much if
you're too cerebral about anything
you're going to [ __ ] it up so I think
you have to balance that with like you
know be drug driven where you need to be
driven but when it comes to the actual
work try not to be like oh my god I
can't mess this up this gotta be great
this guy I mean I want to film school
with guys that run around they were like
oh my god I got this movie's heavy
perfect Stevens few words gonna see this
and it's going to be you know it's like
you you get hysterical that's not going
to help you so drive and hysteria are
two different things and I think you
have to just slippery slope yeah but ya
know desperation doesn't doesn't fish
nada is that it's not attractive to
anybody you know and I get reminded of
it you know if I call my agent about too
many times about this otherwise but he
heard back from a particular TV show or
you know
got feedback from even like if it's like
did you get feedback from that meeting
you know it's like like he'll put me you
know I mean we're friends that he can
you know a nice sarcastic way remind me
to just chill out and that like that's
not that that's not helping anybody like
at that point it's out of my hands like
I need to and one of the things to do at
that point is then just to immerse
yourself in the next thing you know and
forget about like whatever happened you
sent that thing off it's out of your
hands you had that meeting it's out of
your hands you know nobody that yes
there is an element of perseverance you
know like you send a script to somebody
and you follow up you make sure they got
it or whatever and you know you kind of
stay on the radar and then there's you
know the weekly check-in which just
means you're going to end up in the
trash can so you know I guess yeah I
mean as soon as it becomes desperation
it's it's it's it's no longer helpful to
you two no longer helpful to your career
and when you find that happening and I
say this to myself Ryan remember this
just go into the next thing and you know
like i said earlier i mean the next
thing for me would be to write the next
thing and know that whatever's out there
is now you know is up to luck and timing
and who sees it and when they see it and
how hungry they were when they saw read
it and if that's what their company was
looking to do with that particular time
so yeah I mean desperation certainly
certainly a big turn-on but you know
it's a yeah I mean ambition ambitions
great and you just got to walk that fine
line